how the gun grip my name appear back
welcome to Ted tenebris Lake it's a
story about a cabin it's raining out of
it that's pretty much all I know
thank you
it's made by the same guys who have made
[Music]
this really scary the one that I play so
everyone keeps saying it's really scary
this one too and I'm like all right I'd
get like out okay think
what could have possibly happened what I
am I don't know what I am
you're a guy in a pajama sitting on a
box and so all right let's do some weird
moments in the rain cuz why not cool all
right
we get to play we're gonna we're gonna
dance a little bit first yeah yeah all
right and close our eyes and then there
we go can i play now for more dancing
yeah all right more dancing there we go
there we go dance my way out of there
that a lake that's gorgeous hey box
thank you so we play this guy in a
pajama we like to sit on boxes that's
all that we knows whoa okay this chapter
takes scare me that's gorgeous Igor
doesn't mean I like it trying to think
about the [ __ ] cousin sorry I play
that they made it's raining through the
ceiling holy [ __ ] that's problem I was
coming where's Felix I'm right here man
no I'm not of course nobody of course
team Christine is lame yeah exactly
what is our lane that's s that Christine
Christine is a poser me however I'm
freakin badass look at that collar holy
[ __ ] so awesome what is that that family
photo that Hitler secret Nazi
Who am I what my my name is father
that's nice let's keep going I guess the
first obstacle not a problem
the third not a problem not a problem
out ok a little problem don't fall down
man
don't what no matter how dark the moment
love and hope are always to perceive
that it's not really true that but hey
what are you
that's ignore you I'm just kidding
how's it going man I Parana you can say
if I click me all right
I'm saving Oh God thank you a save
station oh all right pretty cool cousin
story so far I quite enjoy it
what
what are you doing red girl let me pass
you you will never pass a speeding
actually I think there was a I was gonna
go here first place but I guess we can
just walk around ha I am too smart for
you red girl whoa whoa your lamps man
they [ __ ] me up why would they do that
sub-tree how ya doin sup mountain ah
Jennifer what are you doing up there
hello fanny I'm stuck I don't dad I'll
come for help Jennifer I swear
stupid [ __ ] I'm just oh whoa whoa
what was that
Wow
hello
[ __ ] freaking me out
anyone here just me right and the rain
drop the file and from my hair I just
like being it and
I guess I got a jump here ah ah ah
I heard man never mind Oh someone like
you
what's going on here what's this place
why is it a barrel here what are you
doing here
you're trapped help it is this pen are
you French Jesus Christ barrel
you trying to hide from me okay well I
guess we've got to go with me Eve wait a
cave all right fine
I'm swimming hey Jennifer I'm still
stuck all right
sorry about that Jennifer I'll be right
there I don't like this
like that uh god damn it this is getting
drying [ __ ] all right
when there is nothing left than darkness
a man can do nothing but wonder what's
become of itself
well darkness obviously cuz I was hard I
was left all right
it's a castle I guess we gotta go there
sorry but you are really ugly plant you
say that you Muppet what plan what are
you doing following me
come on plant whoa nice 360 a.m. oh I
admire some new plants I got my eyes on
you [ __ ] stalkerish plants man
we're following your pee we're working
with the barrels baby
god damn you barrels barrel plants all
right let's go and the dungeon and the
woods are lovely dark and deep but I
have promises to keep and miles to go
before I sleep
now that rhyme the woods are lovely dark
and deep but I have promises to keep and
miles to go before actually I should be
around all right
chapter 2 done this reminds me of SP all
aye aye
Wow whoa the hell is this this is the
entrance to the dungeon uh-huh
you see that big door I think that door
is preventing anyone from escaping this
place what about that door I came from
that see Nautilus grab the key for the
machine where the lever is located huh
the machine room perhaps it's over here
I don't think so hello hi how you doing
there hello everyone
yeah yeah yeah you got a nice nice swag
there brother how's it going everyone my
name is Sammy sooo cool cool name brah
yeah yeah so creepy yeah
Sammy can you tell me how to open the
door and stop being in awkward positions
when I'm talking to you fine baby
fine the door is in the machine stop
what'd I tell you about the awkward
position sorry I just like scissoring
dude starving man I'll leave you there
Sammy sir
god damn Sammy sue what's going on in
here
hello it's pretty well made cousin sorry
I've got to tell him what's going on in
here
nothing let's go down here hmm
[ __ ] is that a lamb Tong
whoa
well you see that sledge a look at this
lantern and I are it looks weird and a
broom - whoa yeah whoa
it's just here I guess we need this I'm
not sure maybe we can find or look at
that haha fail there we go there we go
maybe we can find a place to put it but
I didn't see any Sammy Sammy Sammy I did
Sam eager that's here oh ah look at that
girl look at that body
wait I need Sammy I'm not going anywhere
without her
Sammy Oh what the [ __ ] she left at fish
I left the doors closed now goddamn
Sammy
well it's creepy man so [ __ ] dark
bars [ __ ] buddy a dirt did you flip
that over having a party here go inside
patty see let's go
oh I'd go inside you think I'm scared
okay I'm I knew it
well what is this
disgusting how do I get rid of this vice
uh-huh die pigs I mean bigger yeah yeah
what the hell oh god damn it it was a
trap I knew it
bad [ __ ] barrel knew it well what do
i do then do you have candles and [ __ ]
on you you try and be romantic and [ __ ]
oh cool that's a lot of keys machine
room key okay I guess we can shake it
out the other side same work no I was
like someone is fapping in there no one
to disturb that
I definitely don't want to run out of
Mile engine all right how about this
door come on man
yes bring it what come on so many doors
all right am I good what the hell was
that
don't sneeze when I'm in class what
ladies walking circles what was the
point of that key let's check over here
I guess
shut up mice no one likes you all right
Sammy
hey Billy I got a friend over here with
scissoring yeah yeah since the masseter
system I said make it stop make it stop
stop stop scissoring disgusting
goddamn you gotta stop stop a kids
watching countdown you well oh no what
what are you doing here man [ __ ] you
come on yeah what am I supposed to go I
really don't know
no Jessie that's why sure Wow and it's
fauna any directions maybe it's in here
come on
I want a net I didn't love it I am ie I
don't know what I'm talking about
that's okay lean to the left lean to the
right go wrong resurrection what
huh wait like this that's a big door did
I open you wow wow wow
alright battle don't [ __ ] I'm out of
shape man I need I need this come on
dude sick sick oh don't be a little
monster can don't feei madder than
watching I thank God I think I'm never
doing a 360 again that's stupid
not funny man not funny no more 36
degrees great sex I just got my did I
Dart
I want okay okay
no three six no more elastic [ __ ] now
Mara that's definite on with me thank
you
there we go three six a yeah you see
that [ __ ] barrels ha ha ha ha drown in
the water
who's laughing now no well I don't care
Sturridge let's go when there is nothing
left in darkness a man can do nothing
but wonder what became of you
well alright so I would like to end here
brown like if you enjoyed this kind of
come bro today sorry there wasn't that
much action here but I think this is
Canada this story that progresses like
slowly and then it brain hits you in the
face but well alright so if you want see
me if you're like oh this is lame every
episode needs action and let me know in
the comments if you want to play sidecar
laughs but I think it's good to change
with more serious cousin or like this
one every wise you know what but yeah
anyway this is Nelson breath
[Music]
without you - town okay pleasure me
offer [ __ ] this